each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay well it's a real pleasure for me to
be introducing ycj here professor from
National University of Singapore I've
known Tay for almost 30 years that when
back when he was a graduate student at
Harvard is when we we first met me ended
up doing a PhD thesis in the database
area on the performance of locking
systems which has which is was really
landmark work at the time and is still
very relevant he uncovered the
abstraction of lock thrashing which was
enough which was behavior that had been
observed but nobody had really
understood it from an analytic
standpoint and also he did a good job in
separating out the the issue of resource
contention for resources other than
locks from the contention that arises
from locks people still read this work
today it's really as relevant now as it
ever was on in general of his work is on
analytic models for performance most of
his research he recently came out with
an introductory book on the topic a
monograph from Morgan Claypool synthesis
series entitled analytic performance
models of computer systems that was just
published last month and you can see a
pointer to that on his webpage online as
well his webpage has a nice pointer to a
to a lecture from a couple of years ago
that he gave on Universal cache miss
equations for memory hierarchies so he
works on hard problems that are of pre
general interest to the to the issue of
performance in computer systems and
today is going to tell us on how to
upsize a database so that you can use it
for performance evaluation of database
systems so and from data side of the
ocean and coming here one thing I
learned is
is to have an advertisement so so as a
few mention this this book just came out
book is a less than 100 pages and out of
it and the idea is to introduce the
elementary performance modeling tricks
to people who have no interest in
becoming performance analyst they just
need have some rough model of how the
system is spoke behaving the detect the
techniques are actually illustrated with
discussion of 20 papers in some work
that was done here so take a look it is
an easy read I promise so upside the
book should be read in soft copy because
the 20 papers are hyperlinked so I don't
know how to autograph electronic they do
they do yeah but it's best rating in
soft copy so this work done with
students died thinking wanna tell our
limiting and soon young the the what I'm
going to do is describe two problems one
I call the datasets killing problem and
then the one the social networks
attribute value problem and of course
introduced up sizer after it's the first
attempt at solving the data set scaling
problem and it has within it what I call
a strong in solution to the attribute
value correlation problem and you will
very soon see why I call it a strong and
solution so the motivation we are in a
big era of big data and big data means
different things to different people you
mean janome data or astronomy data but
in our context here I'm talking about
Internet services so some of these
applications have insane growth rates
and if I imagine if you I developer of
the of something that you aspire to be
the next Twitter you worry that you
that your system is going to grow so
large next- that your data set is going
to grow so nice next month that your
system may not be able to cope with it
so if you are looking forward you might
want to test the scalability of your
system with some by definition synthetic
data set all right so how can you do
that one one way to do so might be to
use TPC benchmarks TPC benchmarks allow
you to specify the size of the data set
you won one gig 1 100 gig and you will
generate it for you and they have
different flavors as well and they're
supposed to be domain-specific but they
are not application-specific if you
think about something like TPC tub deal
which is supposed to be for e-commerce
and Amazon and eBay are both roughly
speaking ecommerce how relevance is this
particular benchmark for amazon or ebay
is not clear so the idea here is that we
want something that's application
specific so rather than design one
benchmark for this application and then
a benchmark for that what we want is one
single to where you come with your data
set and I'll scale it up for you so the
data set scaling problems is that you
give me a set of relational tables and
outsider the r is big capitalized
because i want to emphasize that with
talking about relational tables so
people don't misunderstand that I'm
upsizing a graph or anything like that
so relational data tables d and a scale
factor s and our generate a data set the
D prime that is similar so here's where
i use my probes so you come to me i'm
outside there you come to me with it
with the data set d and i'm going to
scale it up to D Prime and this two are
going to be similar the trick here of
course is what does it mean to be
similar right it could be statistical
properties normal the statistical
properties in here must be similar to
the statistical properties in here or it
could be grafted I take you know d if
this is generated by a user by
network then the social network here
must be similar in some sense so when
defining the problem I wanted age since
sub sizer is supposed to work for
different applications I want a
definition of similarity that its
application in that will work for any
application so the our our our way
around the problem is i'm going to
imagine it when you come to me with the
data set you also have in mind a certain
set of queries that you're going to run
and then the way you're going to judge
whether d prime and d are similar is
going to run the query on d prime and
see whether is what you expected so that
there's how you're going to judge where
the d prime is so as suggested by this
when we conceived the problem we were
thinking about upsizing that's why we
call it up sizing ass bigger than once
killing it with bigger than one but when
i went around and talked to people it's
think that there's some interest in same
sizing making a copy that is the same
size why would you want to make a copy
this the same size well very scenarios
for example i'm a vendor and and you
hire me you have a data set and you hire
me to do something of your data set but
you'd want to show me your real data set
so what i can do is a run-up sizer to
make a copy a synthetic copy and then
you let me work with the synthetic data
same that's one possibility another
possibility in the cloud setting is that
people are you may want to test a
different layer for your data set in the
cloud or you might want to test a
different index implementation or
whatever but so you want to do all of
this in the cloud but you don't want to
upload your data into the cloud so what
you might do is you generate a synthetic
copy in the car
or you know for people who already are
working in the crowd and they want to do
some experiments somewhere else in a
crowd you'd want to ship all the data
there right so what you might want to do
is no extract the statistics you go
there and then you blow it up and you
get a synthetic copy so various
scenarios they can think of but actually
when I talk to a particular company damn
this is a big company and and they have
no shortage of big data sets what you're
actually interested in is the downsizing
so why would you be interested in
downsizing dude for them they see that
their customers are struggling with
trying to get a sample of your data set
so you have a data set this year big and
then you have some prototype application
that you want to debug now heaven forbid
that you run your prototype pratap
application on this big data set so you
want to take a small sample of the data
sets and then you give up your
application they're sampling was so
difficult about centering if this thing
has a million users and you want to test
your application on a thousand users you
just randomly simple a thousand users
right what's so difficult well it's not
so simple because you you might randomly
sample a thousand users and these
thousand users know somehow is connected
referring some object and those objects
somehow connected with some other users
and then you have to pull out those
users and it's like spaghetti and in the
end you get way more than a thousand
users so for for various reasons you
might also be interested in downsizing
now the upside the algorithm will work
for all or this tree instances okay so i
would like to say that there's no
previous world but i'll be lying so i
already mentioned TPC benchmarks and if
you trace it backwards you get a
wisconsin bench months and that was done
by 27 years ago and in the Wisconsin
benchmark the relations are completely
synthetic and that particular approach
so meaning there
is not they did not try to scale it up
from some empirical data and and a
particular approach propagated down to
the TPC benchmarks and that's how they
do it so it's not that they did not
consider the possibility of scaling our
empirical data set but they have some
problems they encounter some prop up
issues when you try to scale up an
empirical data set and you try to make
the statistics are the same if your
table has only 20 tuples then you worry
whether this 20 topples is telling you
anything about the real the underlying
distribution right so they did they for
us this is not a problem because the
data says we are dealing with nowadays
are so huge that there's no problem
another problem that the encounter was
why were they interested in this
synthetic data sets well they wanted to
compare a particular vendors offering
against another vendor right use these
benchmarks to do this comparison now
when you want to do this comparison if
you don't just have the data set you
actually run some queries and you want
to tune your your data and your queries
so that you can test the joint
algorithms or the buffer management or
whatever so this tuning is much easier
if everything isn't acting if you use
empirical data set is much harder to do
the children from me here the way I've
formulated a problem could you look
weary I won't be the queerest the one
that I'm gonna run tomorrow morning to
run my business
you know the less they can be human the
more honest Avenger Bob would be pleased
other benchmarking much so so so you you
you want to bench you you want to have a
benchmark where you can test these
vendors offering against that vendor so
you want to tune the queries etc so that
you can test what this what this system
is actually doing versus what that
systems actually do ok I want to do
research on the database yes usually
don't use er no ok this was this was the
particular argument so far for us is
it's not an issue because up sizer
doesn't worry about the queries after
things assumes that you have a set of
queries in mind but it doesn't it it
doesn't make use of the set of queries
for example okay so this this is
important to remember right is in
formulating the problem is entirely or
in formulating the solution is entirely
possible to factor in the set of queries
that you want to answer in doing the
upsizing but we don't do that okay the
third question the third problem that
they came up against was that scaling
and empirical data set is hard and
they're saying that the data set scaling
problem is hard but it's been 27 years
is a long time in this business and it's
about time we take another crack at a
problem okay so for you guys assume I
don't go through this i'm going to use
the flickr data set so in the flickr
data set users upload photographs and
and make comments and tag the
photographs etc and my job is to upsize
it right okay so in the figure data set
you have a photo table with primary key
and a foreign key values that indicate
who uploaded the photograph and then you
have non-key attributes for the data
size etc so the user ID here is pointing
to another table so is the primary key
for another table with with a username
look
user location etc and these are the
non-key attributes and then you have a
comment table which says that this
particular user commented on this
particular photograph and a tech table
that says this but grey user tagged this
particular photograph so what you get
now is a schema graph ok what
assumptions do we use so we start with
the following i'm going to assume that
the primary key is just a single to an
attribute sometimes it could be too but
right now I assume there's just one I'm
going to assume that a table has at most
two foreign keys so in the example that
i'm using the the user table has no
foreign key the photo table has one
foreign key the tech table has two
foreign keys and the comment table to
foreign keys that's it no no treatment
keys I'm going to assume that a schema
graph is a sacred I'm going to assume
the degree distribution static now I'm
going to define what degree distribution
means let me give you the intuition
first so a user will pose a number of
comments so if you take a histogram you
can change the into its into a
distribution that says with probability
so and so you upload you know one
photograph to photograph etc I'm going
to assume that this distribution is the
same so the degree distribution for this
and the degree distribution for this is
the same that is not necessarily
reasonable right think about why we want
to do this you want to do this because
you're afraid that when when the data
set gets to be this size are your system
cannot cope so there's a time element
involved so if you are thinking about
loading photographs by the time you get
to hear everybody would have loaded more
photographs right the tail of the
distribution would have shifted so it's
maybe not reasonable to assume that the
degree distribution static but for the
time being let's let's use that
assumption i'm going to assume the
non-key attributes depend only on the
key value so the non-key attributes here
only depends on on the key values that
means let's say in the case of the user
table this values here only depend on
the key values don't depend on the other
tables and just hang on you're a top
what this thing is completely syntactic
i mean this this thing has no meaning
what does it mean to to depend on this
so what it means is that this values
here can be independently generated so
when you give me the empirical data set
i'm going to mine it i'm going to find
out what the distribution on the edge
the sex the names etc and i'm gonna use
those distributions to independently
generate the values here and later on I
will be worried about correlations but
at the moment list assumed as
independent ok so for for the other vote
for for more sophisticated tables like
this one then this one in general is a
is a function of this this key values
right so if I know that the dis users a
gardener that there could be a function
that tells me what you that you should
be what attack that is what comments
non-key attributes might be over here so
there is non-trivial the correlation is
not trivial okay
and I'm going to assume that the data
correlations are not induced by a social
network and that's not true for the
flickr network but let's just use this
simplifying assumptions for the time
being so up sizer uses three ideas the
first idea is a degree and it's really
simple this user uploads for photographs
over the degree of y tu foto is for and
user x make two comments so the degree
of x to comment is to the degree the
user why make one comment so that you
have y 2 comments 1 you look at it for a
moment and you realize that one talking
about here is a bipartite graph so every
schema ish induces a bipartite graph
among the top holes here and the degree
is just talking about the degree of the
bipartite graph that's why this all use
that terminology the next thing we worry
about is the joint degree distribution
so I'm a user I upload so many
photograph there's my degree and I met
so many comments and that's my degree
and this two degrees are going to be
correlated because the user lies to
comment on its own photographs so we
have to respect that correlation in a
table like comments for a something like
social network you imagine that the
users would might be there might be a
social network for gardeners the social
network for birdwatchers etc and then
the photographs might be trusted around
flowers or kites or cars or whatever and
it's more likely that a gardener would
comment on the flower so there's some co
clustering distribution that we we have
to respect so for a table with two
foreign keys the way up sides I do with
the correlation between the two foreign
keys is to look at a co clustering
distribution
so these are the three ideas that we
work with the algorithm is quite simple
the first thing we do is we sort the
four tables so remember that there's a
schema grab on the four tables so when
we salt it the first one to come up will
be the one with no foreign key and then
the one we foreign keys pointing to
whatever has already come out like this
one's photo and then the ones with
foreign key is that point to whatever
else has come off like this too and this
will be the order in which we generate
the tables okay so how do we generate on
the user table so your empirical data
set has a million users you want to
upsize it to two million very simple I
just generate two million primary key
IDs and then for each one of them I
generates the result of non key values
okay and that's done then the fourth
sorry so remember the assumption that
anon key values only depend on the key
values and since in this case the key
values have no meaning that means that
the non key values is a function of this
one in the some trivial way right so
that means that I can independently
generate the non key values so there's a
link or an environment have a certain
length distribution yeah so I mind this
guy for them for the name distribution
for the age distribution sex whatever
and then I use those two to generate
those values so for at this moment I
don't I don't worry about for relations
right so I just generate them
independently you've not young wanna
live in your competition
just distribute characters of the eight
so in this first cut version of App
sizer we are focused on the key values
so we don't do anything sophisticated
with the non key values so the next
thing to generate is the photo table so
how do we do that photo tables now
remember that so the first thing we do
is remind this for the degree
distribution degree from user to photo
know each user uploads how many
photographs so we know that distribution
I have two million users here so what I
do is for each one of them I pick a
degree value from the distribution so
user number one uploads has degree 3 so
we uploads three photographs of user
number 1 I generate three tuples does
user number 2 has five photographs I
create five top folks done so that's
easy now now for the correlation for the
case where there are two foreign key
values right what I'm going to do is I
have to assign a degree from the user
table to this column and a degree from
the photo table to this column now they
degree from the degree from the from the
user table 2 discs this column is
correlated with you user to photo and
that one has already been generated so I
have to take a conditional probability
okay no problem so as long as it respect
their correlation the other thing I have
to worry about is a correlation in these
two columns so for the correlation in
these two columns what I do is first I
generate a comment ID I know the code
clustering distribution so now I just
assigned a comment ID to a co cluster so
let's say I assign it a coke roster for
gardener and flowers now after have a
sign into a co cluster or gardener and
flowers I have to pick a particular
gardener have a bigger particular flower
so this gardener upload our commented on
10 flowers and that gardener commented
on tree flowers then with higher
probability a I assigned the comment
with that particular garden so it's
common sense and this is what i do i
generate ID assign it to a podcaster i
pick a coke last i pick a user in a cool
class that in the user class according
to the degree pick a photograph
according to the degree when i'm done
with that I would have the three key
values once I have the three key values
the non-key attributes only depend on
the key values so I can generate the
rest of them and there will be one
topple and then I do this so every time
a signed photograph or two it's a sign
comment to him I reduces degree assigned
to a flower i reduced its degree and i
do that until until the degrees of zero
and then i generate the tech table
similarly so it's very simple the the
the actual algorithm itself the complete
algorithm itself has certain
complications but the basic ideas are
already here so relaxing the assumptions
suppose the primary key have two
attributes then what we do is we create
a synthetic attribute as a key primary
key we work with the fake primary key
and then when we are done generating
everything we throw away the primary key
the synthetic diamond key suppose it has
more than two foreign keys now the
co-clustering of the two foreign keys we
can use any algorithm is orthogonal to
upsize if he has three foreign keys well
just find me a three-dimensional co
clustering algorithm and i'll work with
that it doesn't matter to us
suppose the degree distribution schema
graph is cyclic and a good example of
that might be the manager relation I
manage the manager is also an employee
then you have a hu like this I think we
can deal with that and if it's a cycle
where one relation goes to another
relation and in comes back I think we
can deal with that too but it is a
arbitrary cycle then I'm not sure how we
should do that remember why we need to
assume this acyclic we need your zoom is
a cyclic because that gives us a way to
sort the tables and we know who to
generate first right but it is arbitrary
cycle no not just like this but like
this and like that and like that
whatever then where do you start no
until somebody gives me a realistic
scenario I'm not going to worry about it
degree distribution is static but
sometimes degree distributions are not
static for example know the number of
countries in the world you can simply up
sighs is that right so for us what we do
is we up sighs it anyway and then we has
your back and that will change the
degree distribution a more interesting
example is this case remember for the
flicker where I say the tilde of the
distribution has shifted okay so suppose
the degree distribution changes there
are various options we can use one
option is that when you come to me with
the empirical data set you also tell me
how the degree distributions change and
then i will use that instead right if
you cannot tell me how the degree
distributions have changed give me two
snapshots and i'll do an export
extrapolation from there if you don't
have to snap shots i can go in here and
i can mine the time take the time column
example and no deduced from the time you
upload your photograph to extrapolate
and say by next month how many
photographs you would have uploaded many
options or for dealing with changing
distribution ok so at Apple's non-key
attributes may depend on its key
attributes so I'm assuming the non-key
attributes only depend on the key
attributes don't depend on other tables
and don't depend on get a tapas so let's
look at one example where it depends on
the other couples know how can we deal
with that so example from the tag in the
case of tag for example if you are but
watcher the tag values you use might be
correlated somehow for example you're
more likely to use bird and tree and sky
less slightly to use car and bicycle or
whatever so in that case there's some
correlation in the tag values here so
how do we do that so the the way we deal
with that is that remember the upsides
our algorithm that is described is based
on the key values so the tables have
already been generated now you want to
fill in the tag values to capture this
correlation so you know that let's say
this particular user used 13 type values
and you're trying to find out try to
defeat that in tag values they are
correlated so what you need to do is
generate a vector of 13 values for this
particular user now what I do is I go
into the empirical data set and then now
simple it from its some type vector and
this type vector presumably will have
some coherence now if I need 13 tag
values and this is too long and just
throw away some of them this too short I
just add some more and when I add some
more I have to respect the correlation
among the tank values which means that
when you give me the empirical data set
I have to mine the correlation in the
tag values it's very compute-intensive
so if you try to capture all the
correlation in
non-key attributes this is going to be a
major pain but if that's what you need
and that's what you need okay up to this
point I think that we have the basic bag
of tricks for dealing with classical
data sets that banking data or retailer
data etc but now comes the hard part
what if the data set will generate it by
social networks the issue there is that
if the if the data if the data is
generated induced by social by social
interactions I have to understand what
kind of correlations what the
correlations look like so that when you
give me the data set I can extract from
it the social interactions or the social
network then I can scale up the social
network and then induce the correlations
use that bigger social net will induce a
correlation in the in a big in the
synthetic data set so I need to know
this mapping right I need to river and
reverse-engineer the social interactions
and I don't know how to do that there's
no literature on this there's a lot of
work on graph theoretic views of social
interactions there's a lot of work on
algorithms for social networks but as
far as I can tell there's no work on a
database directing view of social
interactions if the database if the
relational database were induced by a
social network what kind of correlations
would have and I've not seen papers of
their kind so since there's no
literature on this we just do some
half-assed thing so this is this is our
hypothesis that friends are similar and
because they are similar they're foreign
key identities can be swapped what does
that mean okay let me give you the
example right
so in the frigate data set I'm going to
define friends as two guys commenting on
each other's photograph okay we take
that as the evidence that they are
friends and you can extend that to
facebook writing on each other's walls
for example similar how do I tell where
the two users are similar we can just
look at the tag vectors so if the if
this guy uses this particular tag vector
and that guy uses that particular tag
that we take a cosine and we see you
said to judge how likely it is that they
are going to be friends okay so now how
to replicate the social network so this
thing is generated by social networks
and I need to replicate that in this
particular data set so the first thing I
do is I go in here and I striked all
those guys who comment on your own
photograph this is a technicality almost
everybody does that and then I because I
define friends as commenting on each
other's photograph I can actually figure
out who are the friends in this
particular data set I can
reverse-engineer it and then now I've
generated the data set the synthetic
data set for that right I remember I've
already generated the tables now what I
need to do is go and tweak the values in
those tables so that I capture the
social network right up to this point I
have not yet done damage right okay so
first of all I need to know how many
pairs to tweak so in the originals in
the original in the empirical data set
there are so many ages so many pairs of
friends now for the synthetic one I
scale it up by s ys shouldn't it be a
square so I check the literature this
thing could be growing exponentially but
then the number of friends you have
doesn't grow exponentially except for
some outliers
so my understanding of that is that in a
social network the way it grows is that
no you had more sub social networks
rather than one social network blowing
up so if it grows by adding sub social
networks then yeah it does skills
linearly so that's that's how we are
going to do it so I'm going to go in and
click the values they attribute values
so that I have this number of friends so
i'll pick em pairs and i'll pick pairs
from from this set and i will decide
whether they are going to be friends or
not by calculating the cosine so if the
cosine is your point tree then we
probably do point 3 and make them
friends so for each pair that i choose
so this guy commented on its own
photograph that guy commented on its own
photograph now I swapped this too and
when I stop this too now the comment on
each other's photograph so that's just
how and we do that for n pairs so that's
how we will generate the social network
for this one okay
enough of that now for some data yeah so
we've crawled flickr to get a base set
f1 and the data we stole it in four
tables and so this this is real values
crowd and then we take the this base set
and then we up sighs it by one meaning
we make a synthetic copy now this do
value should actually be the same it is
just a floating-point thing so this is
not no problem so this is measuring the
table sizes number of tuples in these
four tables this tape this table is
generated by the degree distribution and
you see that the disagreement is already
significant those two tables are
generated by the co clustering and
apparently it was differently and then
we crawl some more so at this point we
have one and a half million comments and
half a million photographs we crawl some
more so f 2.8 one is a data set where it
has 2.81 times the number of users in f1
and we did a similar thing and I let you
judge how well this works
so this is the one with the most severe
disagreement and it's not clear why that
is so it could be that comments have
some profit recursive property when I
comment on your stuff you know comment
on my stuff and it blows up something
like that so this is comparing the table
sizes but I said that we should judge
the quality of up sizer by by looking at
the queries right so we tested it on for
queries taking joints different number
of joints and here you see what we got
and it's think the things pretty dizon
up to this point and this is you know
you can look at it as no estimating
joint sizes and one comment that I got
from some people was dead no this kind
of estimate should be built into query
optimizers so anyway so this is
estimating this these are queries 9.1
points is it a real data bit of liquor
or a concern this is real it's real so
these are real so these are your
outsiders yeah so this one is the king
the original real data set up sighs it
by 9.11 yeah so so this these are this
exercise this is checking the the the
the weather we were able to capture the
correlation among the key values now
what about a non key values so we we
tested retrieval on the non key value
like bird the tag value so that you know
the type value Dementor the bird here
for example and the agreement is not so
great now it's okay here but for the
smaller sizes it's not so great and it's
not clear to me why is it's bigger for
because it's better for bigger sets and
not so
on a smaller set we didn't try very hard
in a case of this this particular query
here we are actually testing whether we
capture the correlation among the key
values that non key values the tech
values and and we didn't try very hard
as a mansion just capturing the
correlation between pairwise correlation
between tech values is already very
compute-intensive if you try to capture
more than do the correlation more among
more than two tech values is horrendous
so we that we didn't try so hard on that
one I imagine that we can improve on
this these values so up to this point
the social network is not in the queries
now we want to test how this performs
were what were the query what what if
the query is referred to the social
networks work with the comparison our
the comparisons load so remember that
after I deals with the query with with
the social network with the swap
techniques so now we have to compare the
real query results against up sizer with
and without so on we're going to see how
it goes so the first query is retrieve
pairs of friends
and you see that without the slop you
completely cannot capture you have
millions of users and millions of
photograph millions of comments the
probability that you and I will comment
on each other's photograph is basically
zero so you really have to go in and
tweak the values you know if you want to
capture the social network then the way
we replicate the social network is to
look at a similarity look whether to
users are similar and the way we check
whether to users are similar is to look
at the tech vectors and so what we want
to see whether this actually a good
reflection on whether they comment on
each other's photographs so you retrieve
X&Y who are friends and have at least 10
texts that they both use and the
agreement is still decent until like
here so maybe we can we can skill not by
a factor of 10 but something less than
that it's ok we should look at it yeah
it could it could just be that you have
something with so remember that the way
we build up this data sets is we crawled
and crawled and crawled and crawled it
could be that there's something wrong
with this something wrong with this
particular data set maybe they were the
way we did a crawling we might have
messed up or whatever it's not clear so
social interactions have structures and
this is the major issue so one structure
would be triangles a friend of a friend
is likely to be a friend we didn't try
we were not so ambitious we just wanted
to catch see whether we can capture the
V shapes x and y are friends and y and z
are friends so can we can capture that
and the answer is clearly no right so
what what happened it was doing well up
to this point so it turns out that yeah
we can scale up the number of friends
accurately but we cannot scale up the
topology it turns out that in Flickr
they are some hot shots with many
friends like this in a star shape and
when we scaled it up to f prime we lost
that starship the starship just
dissipated so we have to figure out some
way of doing it now and it may be it has
to do with the way we use the type
remember we replicate is that the branch
of graph by talking by by looking at a
similarity and similarities and define
in terms of tag vectors so currently if
this tag vector will Berg chicken and
this vector is Burt's hen then the
cosine zero so you know imagine you can
actually do better than that right you
put in an ontology or whatever but my
students tell me that you need a lot
more than just that that the know you
really you will fix some of the some
some of the structural issues but but
you can't fix all of it so I described
to problem first is the dataset scaling
problem and as I say I know we softsub
sizer bit head has what i believe the
basic set of techniques for scaling up
anything desk classical data set but
when it comes to the non-key attributes
there are all kinds of correlations in
real data and I imagine that the kind of
correlation is one application is
interested in might be different from
the kind of correlation another
application is interested in so if up
sizer is to be a tool that will work for
any application we are going to need a
lot of help
we can't do this ourselves so we are
releasing a sizer as open source and
hope that if it is useful for people
then people will contribute by by making
the relevant changes additions to do
them the other problem that I introduce
is the social networks attribute value
correlation problem quite a mouthful I
can't figure out some shorter way of
describing this problem and will be the
first to admit that that the sub
technique is at all does it's not going
to generalize so what would be a general
technique of replicating a social
network in a relational data spectator
set here we need some kind of theory to
help us right now because there's no
database directing work on social
networks we don't know what to do and if
there was some theory built around this
this the relationship between the social
network and the relational data set then
we can it gives us something to work
with and I think it is a is a wide open
problem is completely blank now anyone
who gets there first will collect the
citations right and you know this is why
I encourage students to do in the
university's you guys are too over that
okay I'll be happy to take more
questions yeah if you run down outsider
their lesson one how well you predict
the past so it's a lot easier to check
predict the past we haven't tried that
we should do that you know this is
something that I intend to do in the
next set of experiments I keep
forgetting to get a numbers so if you if
you want to capture the non key
attribute it could take days but this
kind of numbers really depends on what
hardware you're using and how how many
of them you throw at it so I mean I
don't know how many food is if you don't
care about the non-key attributes you
only upsizing the the key you only worry
about a correlation among the keys I
think for f1 it was some of the order of
an hour to two male to do to make copy
to make synthetic copy and f1 is one and
a half million comments and half a
million photographs this is naturally
parallelize some part of it can be
paralyzed but I think there was some
other parts that they don't paralyzed so
well I think no this sequence this
sequence of generation cannot be
paralyzed so well in general here these
two guys both refer to these two guys so
these two tables have to be generated
together but I imagined that they do you
know you can change the code so that you
can generate these two in parallel and
furthermore there could be some other if
you go deeper into hierarchy there could
be some other correlations that use a
completely different set of keys and
then that since those refer to a
completely different set of keys those
can be generated independently of this
too so some part of it can be paralyzed
but this particular sequence it would
have to be sequential write that one has
to come first then that one then this do
it it seems like you could have a
preprocessing face the figures our local
parallelisms opportunities are you just
analyzing foreign key relationships
really
figure out what
electrician
you might not even need to do that you
just put them in the queue and then just
take them off the queue whichever has
been done OIC just queue up this this
tables right then if you either if the
process is either you can just pull out
the next one to generate it also
horizontally I mean it is your of this
table yeah you're following pairs
foreign keys but within a table yeah if
you are if if you assume that this
couples are don't have correlations then
you can generate the tuples in parallel
this very fine grain kind of parallel
great valentine